how do you feel about potentially
testifying in the trial that we watched
around the world
I mean anytime you're
you're up in the public
school so I mean it's daunting but I
look forward to it you know what I mean
because
I have nothing to hire I'm the only one
that has been telling the truth and
you know I can't shame me anymore so
I feel like if they don't
it Paints the picture that they know
something about me that makes me
you know untrustworthy or not reliable
um so you want to have I do I do I think
having them call me in and put me on the
stand
legitimizes my story and who I am and if
they don't it almost feels like they're
hiding me and people will automatically
assume I would that oh that she must not
be a good witness she's not credible
like so there's no doubt if they ask you
to testify you will testify oh
absolutely